welcome to the place known as Krakow
lambier or cracked land
this is a giant lawless street market in
Sao Paulo where addict buying consume
rock cocaine
at night you see their lighters
flickering in the dark over their crack
pipes as they smoke the world's most
destructive drug we say that they are
like a zombies because they they are
they lost a lot of weight they if we
could talk to the energy you cannot see
much you lost some of humanity assume
will be using crack for years on end of
course see the structure of your brain
change this is the edge of crack land
it's too dangerous to go in and film
openly with a camera that we've just
walked through and you get a real sense
of how overwhelmed the authorities have
been here by the scale of the crack
epidemic in this city the drug now is
effectively legal on the corner here
people are smoking rock cocaine around
the corner there as well in the main
part of crack land and the police are
here too but they can't do anything
about it pop of stand back
this bedlam is a world away from the
image Brazil is attempting to project as
a World Cup host here the drug abuse is
non-stop being a crack addict is
all-consuming Familia Spinelli's ELISA
like they say their family is the pipe
the rock several of my friends who
smoked with me say I am carrying my
husband who is your husband they would
take out their pipe and show me there
are more than a million users in Brazil
that's 1 percent of the adult population
the social cost is enormous with rising
violent crime as the economy has grown
so has the appetite for drugs and with
fierce competition amongst the drug
lords it means prices are low users can
stay high all day for just a few pounds
much easier to get crack from getting
anything else and we're talking about a
very addictive addictive drug that it's
the cheapest in the world in Sao Paulo
the authorities are trying to help
addicts recover but for every success
story like desi raid who's been clean
for three years
there are many failures these are drugs
you use it in five seconds go to there
to to remind you need the drugs every
time it's epidemic
it's in Brazil it's it's terrible when
you look in some war in Brazil they talk
now of a lost generation with so many
young people destroyed by crack it's
easy to see why
Alex Rossi Sky News Sall Paulo